good evening my name is Emma Klausner
and I'm a senior biochemistry major from
Walled Lake Michigan tonight I have the
honor of introducing Homer Hickam mr.
Hickam is a historian and author a
graduate of Virginia Tech mr. Hickam is
a former lieutenant of the US Army's 4th
Infantry Division he was awarded the
Bronze Star and Army Commendation medals
for his service in Vietnam after the war
he worked for the army Missile Command
and in 1981 he became a spacecraft
designer an astronaut training manager
for NASA
where he worked until 1998 mr. Hickam is
the recipient of the University of
Alabama's clearance Cason award and the
Appalachian heritage writers award he is
the author of numerous books including
torpedo Junction and the memoir rocket
voice which was adapted into the film
October sky please join me in welcoming
mr. Homer Hickam
Thank You Emma you did a great job
I gave her an autographed copy of my
latest carrying Albert home and it says
thank you for the great introduction see
I knew you were going to do it you I
just that sense that well it's great to
be back to Hillsdale College one of my
favorite places in the world and dr.
Arnn mrs. Arne thank you for for
greeting me and and bringing me up here
and I always love to come to come here I
was amazed I looked out my window today
and somebody painted the whole place
white and it's just incredible that that
occurred I was talking to I know I have
a lot of things to talk about tonight
it's a big subject the 1960s of the
space race so generally I just talk off
the cuff because I'm talking about
myself which is easy you know but
tonight I'm gonna be talking about what
happened during the 1960s the great
space race that occurred there so I
actually have little bullets here if
it's gonna keep me on on track so if you
forgive me when I look down and go where
am I and then I know so just keep track
of that I was talking to some beautiful
young women they collect to me
they're hoping I'm Jake Gyllenhaal they
say and then they show up and they're
disappointed you know I know how that
goes but I say any time I give a speech
the first thing I do is try to get the
audience to feel sorry for me and so I'm
going to try that right now
my house got blown away by Hurricane
Irma down in st. John down to the
foundation and made my wife cry so but
we got bill back it's all good
so all right okay you're on my side now
right all right terrific oh yeah there
you go
ah anyway yeah yeah usually the reaction
I get oh well you have enough money to
have a second house down at st. John you
know I don't care if it get blown away
but anyway that's right no I'm just
kidding no but I was asked to to give
this speech it's a challenge to talk
about everything that happened in the
1960s and generally as I said I talked
about the various memoirs that I've
written and or maybe some of the books
that I've written so it's easy I know I
know the topic background for is I just
talk up the cuff but I can say that I
actually do have you got to realize I'm
not as old as I look I was actually not
working for NASA during this era was
either in college or in the Army during
the 1960's but I do have a direct
connection to the great space race that
occurred and so let me tell you really
quick because I don't have much time
matter of fact I'm going to set my
little watch right now to countdown
we're going to have a Q&A afterwards by
the way and and and and please ask me
something that you can't or you can't
look up on Wikipedia that's my challenge
to you okay
because I know when you asked me and I
start talking that half of the audience
is gonna be looking at Wikipedia to make
sure that I know what I'm talking about
and I may not but in 1960 I was a senior
in high school in southern West Virginia
the little coal town of coal wood west
by god-- Virginia and going to Big Creek
High School and
I was enamored by the Russian Sputnik in
1957 an F that I started building
rockets you could some of you know this
story already and I was we were the boys
the rocket boys of Ko would were
selected to go to the National Science
Fair and this is my in my book rocket
boys it's not in the movie I don't know
why but so this real thing real happened
lots of witnesses
there I was with $20 in my hand that my
mother had given me to go over to the
county seat of McDowell County in
southern West Virginia to buy a suit so
that I could wear it to the night I
didn't own a suit to wear it to the
National Science Fair and I went into a
men's store called Belcher and Muniz
they knew my my my brother well he spent
a lot of money there but I was new to
this place and I came walking out
wearing a suit that in reflection was
essentially orange they dragged it out
of the basement aid they knew they
they'd finally were able to sell this
suit but I thought it would look great
because you know I was going to show up
and true story I come I must tell you
it's what I'm about to tell you it's a
true story as amazing as it is it really
happened so I stepped outside of Belcher
money and I heard the United States Navy
fights on Anchors Aweigh being played
down the street on a loudspeaker and so
I walked down there to see what was
going on and who should I see standing
on top this was May 1960 standing on top
of a Lincoln Town Car
but John F Kennedy himself he wasn't
president he was but a senator and he
was running against Hubert H Humphrey to
win the West Virginia primary if he won
the West Virginia primary then everybody
felt well West Virginia's vote for him
he might be presidential fodder so he
was running it so he was standing on top
of this
in town car giving a speech he was
surrounded by coal miners who had just
come out of the mine and they were there
in their dirty clothes and their black
helmets tipped back on their heads in
Caron at lunch buckets listening to this
fella from Massachusetts and nobody
could understand a word he said and he
was raving and punching the air and we
were all standing and I got into a
little crowd there and we're all just
standing there there with our mouths
gape and he finally I think he was
talking about food stamps I really do it
was first it was a student a food stamp
speech to coal miners who'd just come
out of the coal mine who didn't need
food stamps but anyway he thought they
did so he wound down and he looked
around I thought rather desperately and
said does anybody have any questions and
nobody did I mean because we didn't know
what he was talking about but I raised
my hand and for some reason he noticed
me right off and and yeah yeah that boy
but the boy and the orange said and so I
said I'm a rocket boy I'd match I said
what do you think we ought to do in
space and I bet Jack Kennedy had not
thought 10 seconds in the entire history
of his life about what we should do in
space and definitely not ever expecting
that question in McDowell County West by
God Virginia and so he said well well
well young man well what do you think we
should do in space and since and since I
was very nearsighted and we had a
telescope the rocket boys did and I
couldn't see Mars or Venus or any of
those but I could see the moon that was
in my head and I said well I think we
should go to the moon it just popped out
of me
and he he said well why do you think we
ought to go to the moon and I said I
looked around always coal miners and I
said we cook they're in mind the blame
thing
true story I don't know it just came out
of me
and all the coal miners they started
laughing and applauding they said you
better believe it West Virginia miners
could go up in mind anything and he said
you elect me president and we will go to
the moon flash forward about 30-40 years
and there I was working for NASA and all
the old Apollo guys were dragging around
the halls and they were they they'd come
in every once a while this during the
shuttle era and they'd say Oh Homer you
should have been here during the Apollo
days it was great and I said well you
never go anywhere if I hadn't asked Jack
Kennedy that question true story I don't
know I don't know how it works that
there's a meaning to everything I guess
but actually I think Verner von Braun
had a lot more to do with it than I did
so here we go I'm gonna start down in my
little bullet charts we got to start
with World War two if we're talking
about the great space race in the 1960s
world war two on one side wasn't United
States and her allies coming through
Europe and on the other side was the
Soviet Union the Russians coming on the
other side and they hit right in the
middle of Germany and it all of a sudden
occurred to a number of people and
especially Winston Churchill that we had
a real problem here we had the United
States of America a huge prosperous
country up against probably the greatest
military land power in the world at that
time the Soviet Union and neither one
liked each other and so we fell into the
great Cold War the United States had
nuclear weapons that we had developed
during the war and the means to deliver
it the Soviet Union did not but it only
took a few years and they were capable
of also building nuclear weapons and
delivering it how did they deliver them
on both sides through aircraft we built
b-47s be
fifty twos hundreds of them we had them
on the runway ready to go at a moment's
notice against the dreaded Soviet Union
which obviously are our enemy and they
were gonna take over the world if we
didn't keep him from do it the Russians
built nuclear weapons they built their
bison bombers they were hundreds of them
they were on runways and the Soviet
Union ready to go at a moment's notice
we were on a hair-trigger for really
global destruction it didn't take too
long President Eisenhower took over in
1952 and he continued this process
recognizing that that we had to counter
the Soviet Union over in the Soviet
Union Joseph Stalin filing died and
Chris javac over and he also recognized
the same thing turned out to be a very
very expensive process of having all of
these bombers and all of these pilots
ready to go so during World War two in
Germany a young man he was only in his
20s by the name of dr. Verner von Braun
developed the v2 rocket he and his team
he they called it the a for Hitler
called it the v2 and it was the most
advanced rocket ever now it was actually
it was the first a man-made device that
actually went into space it could go up
to 80 miles and I had a range of a
little over 150 miles it was just
perfect
to launch from the Netherlands and hit
England which is what they did a couple
of hundred of them he had England there
was no way to stop him they were
supersonic as they came rolling in you
didn't know that they were attacking you
until they blew up so both on the
American side and the Russian side they
understood that what they needed to do
was developed rockets that would carry
nuclear warheads and be a lot cheaper
than having all of these bombers an
interesting thing was occurring the
Russians once they were able to build
atomic bombs they were real heavy bombs
and they the Russians have I worked with
Russians a little bit on the
international space station and I
understood their engineering
technique and that is when they build
something that works they stop that's it
it works I don't have to make it any
better
Americans just keep tweaking and making
it better and refining it and so on and
so we did we kept shrinking our nuclear
weapons down smaller and smaller so they
were lighter and lighter and so when it
when the technology came when Vertov on
Brown came across the Atlantic on
Operation Paperclip
clip and started working for the army
down in White Sands and later up at
Redstone Arsenal in Huntsville Alabama
the the nuclear weapons were starting to
get lighter and lighter and lighter on
the American side and so the throw
weight of carrying these nuclear weapons
5,000 miles meant that you didn't have
to have that big of a rocket but over in
the Soviet Union they needed a great big
bad rocket to carry all of this stuff so
verna von Braun and his team came across
as I said they lived in Huntsville
Alabama as soon as they came in to
Huntsville Alabama about half em didn't
have wives so they basically sent back
to Germany for for their women kind of a
mail-order German brides came across
Wernher von Braun married his cousin his
family sent their cousin over he married
her so they settled in Huntsville they
started the first library they started
the first symphony they started the
first opera there and it's a little
cotton town of Huntsville Alabama and
they formed a Jeffersonian Society they
really tried to become good Americans
and and ultimately they did they learned
a lot about what life was like in the
United States and they studied the
Constitution and so they really worked
hard to become good Americans but they
were military they worked for the army
which was important later on there was a
there was a counterpart to Verner von
Braun over in the Soviet Union and his
name was Sergei Korolev now Sergei when
the Russians came across during world
war ii they captured Peenemunde ii which
was the main test site of the German v2
and
or a four and they captured quite a few
of the v2s and quite a few of the
technicians if you will and Sergei
brought them across to the Soviet Union
studied the v2 disassembled at retro
engineered it learned everything he
possibly could from the Germans until he
could build his own d2 over the United
States Verner von Braun was building his
version of the v2 for the army it was
called the redstone rocket basically
stressed out
v2 and that's as far as the United
States would let him go that's what they
wanted him for basically a big artillery
round that would carry a nuclear warhead
a couple of hundred miles in the mean
time for the bigger rockets and so on
they gave that to some of the
contractors to build the what later
became the Atlas intercontinental
ballistic missile and then the Titan
intercontinental ballistic missile
then came 1957 the International
Geophysical Year where the United States
and the Soviet Union were principal
players we were we gathered together
under this under the igy to learn more
about the earth we said we knew
surprisingly little about the
geophysical earth for instance up to
that point we were not sure about the
drifting continents we we just kind of
thought that oh wait I looked on the map
growing up and I'd see you know what
South America looks like it could fit
into Africa anybody but now just a
coincidence that as it turned out as it
turned out the International Geophysical
Year helped us learn about once upon a
time the earth just had one big
continent called Pangea
and then it all broke up to become the
continents that we don't know today that
was one of the one of the things that
came out of the International
Geophysical Year plus the lot of study
done in down in Antarctica and the
Arctic about our weather patterns and so
on but one of the things that both
countries the Soviet Union and the
United States proposed was to put a
satellite into orbit
now nobody had it had been propositioned
that it was
possible to put a man-made object in
orbit that is once it was up there it
would just continue around the world
like the moon did except it would be
man-made but nobody had ever done that
before or imagined that it could be done
this early on of course we had Robert
Heinlein and Isaac Asimov and arthur c
clarke and all the great science fiction
writers were talking about that but
nobody had actually done it so both the
Soviet Union and the United States
proposed that they would do this the
United States felt like it was an
entirely civilian effort so they ignored
Verner von Braun and his team in
Huntsville and hired some folks that
were working for the United States
United States Navy to create a whole new
liquid propelled rocket with a lot of
advanced techniques like gimbal rocket
engines and so on it's called the
Vanguard project and it was supposed to
fly sometimes May maybe late 1958 but
Sergey Korolev had no and the Soviet
Union had no such scruples about a
civilian program they had a great big
bad rocket that was designed to carry a
very heavy Russian nuclear warhead 5,000
miles and by not flying something that
heavy but something quite a bit lighter
they could put it right into orbit and
so by golly that's what they did they
put in they launched Sputnik that really
knocked this this country on its ear I
mean the Soviet Union didn't really
think that much about it it was
announced that we've launched a
satellite and if you go to this radio
frequency you can you can hear it go
beep beep beep and it's all well and
good and we do this for our
international brothers and sisters
meanwhile the United States is going
absolutely eight over this say we could
not believe it that the Soviet Union
those Russians had beat us into space we
couldn't stand it therefore consequently
without a doubt they were ahead of us in
everything that's the way we took it we
just went berserk over this thing oh my
gosh the Russians are going to take over
the world if we got to do something
about this now right now and so I mean
President Eisenhower I mean come on he'd
been through d-day
it's not a big deal so they said well
I'm not too worried about and everybody
jumped on you yeah you better be worried
about we're behind on everything do
something so he went to Vanguard people
and say I think you'd better launch that
satellite like right now so Sputnik was
launched in October and the first week
in December the Vanguard people dragged
their little rocket out on the launch
pad and put their little little Vanguard
satellite on top of it and took a deep
breath set a prayer push the button it
blew up I mean it really blew up you got
about three feet off the launch pad I
mean I was building Rockets back in
Coalwood we were ahead of the Vanguard
program we were getting at least a
thousand feet by now they got three feet
and blew up oh my gosh world's coming to
an end and President Eisenhower relented
and said dr. von Braun what can you do
and so Wernher said I can put something
in orbit in two months just give me a
go-ahead they gave him a go-ahead took
the redstone rocket stuck some solid
Rockets on top of it and tomorrow let's
see it was launched in 1958 so somebody
did some quick math 60 years tomorrow
was the launch of United States first
satellite Explorer 1 now it was quite a
bit lighter than the Sputnik had gone it
by then they launched the second Sputnik
that had the dog in it like and which
was quite heavy and so we knew that we
were really really behind and so even
though Wernher von Braun was was going
to do his best to help us catch up the
whole country was in trouble this caused
a sea change and a lot of things not
only in technology but also in academia
I'd like to say that the Russians
launched Sputnik in 1957 in 1958 the
United States launched his students when
I showed back up in high school in
September 1958 yeah we were reason about
then June July and August
summertime let's all party started in
September we had plenty of time but
anyway when I showed up in September all
these books were thrown at us and all
these new standards and the rigor of the
academics I mean everybody what what we
call stem now that was the focus we got
to get we got to catch up with the
Russians we are so far behind so it
completely changed the academic
standards in this country it was pretty
amazing to go through meanwhile
President Eisenhower said well we need a
civilian agency to take over and allow
us to catch up in space so they took the
National Advisory Committee on
aeronautics called naica which was a
federal commission that studied aviation
and advanced techniques they brought
them in they brought in Verna von Braun
and his team from Huntsville Alabama
informed the Marshall Space Flight
Center up in Langley that was a aviation
center they brought it in the Cape which
was an Air Force Station Cape Canaveral
brought them in Houston JSC wasn't
formed at that time and basically formed
a brand new federal agency called the
National Aeronautics and Space
Administration which was given the job
of in any way they they cows did in a
lot of federal leaves but ultimately it
was like we got to catch up to the
Russians and then we got to beat them
and so that was really
NASA's charge and it was people in space
that that they really felt like was
where we might be able to catch up we
obviously with the artificial satellites
that were in orbit we couldn't have the
first of that at all so maybe we could
catch up with people in space and we
knew the Soviet Union was interested in
that because they had sent poor
like into orbit on Sputnik 2 I feel so
sorry for that dog I do I mean I get I
get kind of teary about that dog I'm
writing a short story right now we're
like a lands and coal would I can do
that because we don't know exactly what
did happen to like but we like it was a
dog stray dog in Moscow that was just
picked up off the streets and she was
basically kept in a cage her whole life
for the rest of her life except for the
week before she flew the engineer that
was in charge of putting her into
capsule took her home and I've got to
hurry up over like it and as she got to
play with her kids with the kids for a
week before she was sent she probably
only lasted about a day in orbit there
they didn't have a good coolant system
so the heat was such but anyway through
likened Sputnik to we knew that the
Russians were planning on putting a man
in orbit yeah we thought it was gonna be
a man I'm sorry but to put a man in
orbit and so or a human in orbit and so
we thought maybe we can beat them with
that and so we created the project
mercury project mercury was the first
project with the idea of putting an
American in space hundreds of applicants
came in to NASA to be the first American
in space ultimately I mean at that time
you got to realize that we didn't really
know what kind of people we should put
in space because we didn't really know
that much about space they were going to
be in weightless conditions and we
didn't even know if you could I don't
know go to the bathroom and weightless
conditions we didn't know if you could
swallow in weightless conditions we
didn't know how your heart would react
in weightless condition we virtually
knew nothing about that situation and so
what kind of people do we need to hire
to be the first Americans in space some
people said well she get trapeze artists
they spent a lot of time spinning around
you know and but ultimately President
Eisenhower said I want test pilots and a
lot of the test pilots like for instance
my fellow West by God Virginia and Chuck
Yeager didn't want to be an astronaut
they had to have a college degree anyway
and Chuck didn't have one of those but a
lot of the test pilots the really ones
that they're high up in test pilot
hierarchy didn't want to do this because
they just said they just saw it as
basically sitting in an artillery shell
being lobbed somewhere you couldn't
really control this spacecraft and Tom
Wolfe famously called it spam in a can
you know you probably all heard that so
they didn't want to do it so it was
actually the next tier down as of test
pilots that that applied altima lee they
picked seven of them Shepard Alan
Shepard Gus Grissom john glenn scott
carpenter Wally schirra Cooper and
Slayton and I got to meet six of them I
think years years and years later
they're really a special breed of folks
for one thing they had to be small it
was the first requirement I think the
the the tallest of him was 5 foot 8 and
they weighed about 150 pounds and
because basically the mercury which was
the first program they just took a
fighter cockpit and put a heat shield on
it it was that tiny they were very very
tiny and no way to go to the bathroom in
it and there wasn't even a porthole in
it until the astronauts insisted you
know be kind of nice to look out the
window and so I mean basically really it
was we just didn't know it going to
launch these astronauts as they came to
be called into orbit and mostly it was
just to see if they survived and you
know States was pretty cautious about
this they sent chimpanzees into orbit
first
also in ballistic tests and so on to see
if they survive meanwhile the good ol
sergey koroliov had a different plan he
was he after like and a couple of dogs
that they launched into orbit they were
ready to go to put a human into orbit
again they had very very reliable rocket
and they also had a lot of throw weight
and so before we could put a human into
orbit in April of 1961 the Russians
Soviet Union launched Yuri Gagarin
by all accounts Yuri Gagarin was a
really sweet man obviously very brave I
don't know if you know it or not but
actually the Vostok spacecraft that they
launched him on he didn't land with it
because they had no way to soften the
impact it came down they didn't land in
the ocean they had to land on land so he
was required at around 50,000 feet to
actually open the door and jump out he
landed separate from his spacecraft that
took a lot of courage I take my hat off
any day
to Yuri Gagarin for what he did but
again the United States went crazy oh my
gosh they've beaten us again what can we
possibly do a month after that Alan
Shepard one of our mercury astronauts
dressed in his little aluminum suit I
mean they were really cool suits he
climbed into a mercury capsule on top of
a Verner von Braun redstone rocket
hardly modified at all and was lobbed
200 miles downrange that was our
response suborbital flight we all went
nutso we caught up don't know we haven't
either because we haven't gone into
orbit oh my gosh we're still in trouble
so this was an amazing thing by then
Jack Kennedy was President of the United
States by the way politically speaking
he'd probably be a moderate Republican
today he would not fit in the Democrat
Party that's another man so anyway so
I'm just
so anyway Jack Kennedy in and I mean
this take this kind of the ultimate
encourage a month after Alan Shepard had
been lobbed downrange basically in a
cannonball he said we're going to go to
the moon we're gonna land an American on
the moon by the way before that he'd
sneak down to Huntsville Alabama and
talk to Verner von Braun and dr. von
Braun said we can do this we can beat
the Russians to the moon
so just dr. von Braun's saying that he
came in front of Congress just a week
after Alan Shepard had done nothing but
getting the cannonball and fly down
rains 200 miles and say I believe that
this nation should commit itself to
achieving the goal before this decade is
out of landing a man on the moon and
returning him safely to earth eight
years later we did exactly that is that
a miracle in that amazing and I could
wax on and on and how we did that but I
let Kennedy speak for himself and I
don't think how we did it but why we did
it it wasn't to explore the moon it
wasn't even to beat the Russians Kennedy
had a loftier goal in mind and this is
what he said in September 12 1962 in
Houston just as the Johnson Space Center
it wasn't called that cause the man
Space Center at that time was just
getting going
he said we choose to go to the moon we
choose to go to the moon in this decade
and do the other things not because they
are easy but because they are hard
because that goal will desert will serve
to organize and measure the best of our
energies and skills because that
challenge is that is one that we are
willing to accept one we are unwilling
to postpone and one which we intend to
win and the others too is for these
reasons that I regard this decision to
shift our efforts in space from low to
high gear as among the most important
decisions that I will make
during my presidency we shall go to the
moon 240,000 miles away we will build a
giant rocket more than 300 feet tall but
the rest of the rocket was done 50 feet
tall we will build a giant rocket more
than 300 feet tall the length of the
football field made of new metal alloys
some of which have not yet been invented
most of which by the way and not have
been invented capable of standing heat
and stresses several times more than
have ever been experienced fitted
together with a precision better than
the finest watch carrying all the
equipment needed for propulsion guidance
control communications food survival on
an untried and untested mission to an
unknown celestial body and then return
it safely to earth re-entering the
atmospheres at speeds of over 25,000
miles per hour seven miles a second
25,000 miles per hour causing heat about
half that of the temperature of the Sun
all we had done was put Alan Shepard in
a stretched out v2 and loved him 200
miles downrange and that was the goal
that Kennedy gave us mercury flew five
times to suborbital and for orbital and
then the next program up was the Gemini
program which carried two astronauts
during the time the mercury and Gemini
John F Kennedy was assassinated and this
country said unanimously to itself that
we are going to do what President
Kennedy promised that we would do no
matter what and by then Vietnam was
starting to heat up and all of the
trouble with civil rights all of this
was starting to heat up
but Americans said almost unanimously we
are going to go to the moon because
President Kennedy said that's what we
were going to
do the Germany program by the way was
designed by a Canadian I think it's the
only spacecraft we ever had designed by
a Canadian was probably the very best
one we ever had Jim Chamberlain was his
name was also called the gust mobil
named after gus grissom who
unfortunately had managed to sink his
mercury spacecraft when it landed by
blowing the door accidentally off in it
that's another story but anyway so Gus
had just helped design the the Gemini
and its purpose was to prove that we
could actually have humans in orbit for
a long period time so it proved that we
could do long duration flights it proved
that we could do orbital rendezvous Jim
white went outside to make a space walk
to prove that we could go outside into
the actually into space itself just
wearing a suit and survived and also
docking which was required for the
chosen way to go to the moon that was
lunar orbital run to the or three ways
possible ways to go to the moon when I'm
was earth orbital rendezvous which
basically you send a couple of
spacecraft up and you join them in orbit
and then and then you go to the moon or
we've direct you launch everything at
once and the whole spacecraft goes and
lands on and then it takes a huge rocket
to do that or the Loom lunar orbiter
rendezvous which what was picked which
basically you carry the whole thing into
Earth orbit they the spacecraft that's
gonna land on the moon comes out turn
comes back joins the living module and
then the whole thing goes to the moon
circle the moon then the lander goes
lands on the moon does the people get
out go I guess my small steps etc they
get back on and they fly back up to the
the orbiting thing so that was it turned
out to be the quickest and actually the
cheapest way to for us to go to the moon
so that was the one and Jim and I proved
that we could do all that then the
Apollo program was the next one coming
up and that was the one to take
Americans to the moon meanwhile over in
the Soviet Union they were having a lot
of truck
they were they had their great big
rocket big bad rocket they would launch
split all the Sputnik saan and they were
launched Yuri Gagarin it wasn't big
enough to go to the moon and so now they
were the ones trying to catch up and
they they built a big rocket called the
n1 which had the unfortunate result that
it always blew up so so for the Apollo
program landing on the moon by the end
of 1969 I'll read read basically what
Verna von Braun said about required the
most sudden bursts of technological
creativity and the largest commitment of
resources 25 billion back in the 1960s
107 billion that would be in present-day
dollars ever made by any nation and
peacetime at its peak the Apollo program
employed 400,000 people and require the
support of over 20,000 industrial firms
and universities clearly well there were
there were too big hurdles to go to the
moon most people focus on the astronauts
and the Apollo capsule on top and the
lander and so on if you ever go down go
down to the well you can go down to the
Cape or you can go to Smithsonian or you
can go to Huntsville the Space and
Rocket Center and you'll see that that's
just a tiny little piece of that whole
thing the rest of it is the Saturn
rocket the Saturn 5 rocket that 300 foot
long rocket that that Kennedy forecasted
that we would end up building that that
was the one at Verna von Braun and his
team built down there and in Huntsville
Alabama that got to be called rocket
city and that's the most amazing machine
probably ever built the Apollo program
itself though began very very troubled
the said the Gemini capsule was was very
good and was built by McDonnell Douglas
and the craftsmen who worked on it
quality control was very very good the
Apollo for some
capsule was not very good and there were
a lot of complaints about quality
control on it and they also made a
decision a rather odd peculiar-looking
reflecting on it decision to make the
interior of the Apollo capsule to be
100% oxygen where the Gemini and Mercury
was basically air pressure this was just
normal air this was going to be a
hundred percent oxygen and the reason
for that was that the human body can
sustain itself on a hundred percent
oxygen but not at atmospheric pressure
this is one of the reasons that scuba
divers get the bends when you go we have
greater pressure below and you come up
then there's nitrogen in the air and the
air comes out in the form bubbles so if
you're in space and you're breathing air
before you can go out and a spacesuit
you have to it has to be lower pressure
if it was around 14.7 PSI 15 psi then
you couldn't even bend your hands the
gloves would be so stiff so it has to be
a lower pressure and another way to do
that is to have five psi breathe pure
oxygen so that's why before the
astronauts on the space station can go
out they've got a pre breathe for a
couple hours to breathe off their
nitrogen and then they get in their
suits and they're able to go out and
work so the Apollo designers said well
we'll just skip that step and we'll just
have them breathe pure oxygen all the
way and that was a really good idea but
not when you your quality control and
your electronics are not very good and a
spark occurs which did occur with the
death of causing the death of three
astronauts Grissom Chaffee and white
when their capsule caught on fire during
a test down at the Cape and so this
caused a huge set of decisions to go
toward much higher quality control a
complete redesign of the Apollo capsule
that fire probably saved the entire
Apollo program because it brought such
rigor into the program that had not been
there before
after this complete redesign which
happened rather quickly it took a year
for them to do it and Apollo was ready
the Saturn 5 came online dr. Verner von
braun his german team and his american
team they were all one team at that at
that point came online with a saturn v
it had seven million five hundred
thousand pounds of thrust biggest rocket
successful rocket ever built and so
between 1968 and 1972 the Apollo program
happened it's pretty amazing really
Apollo 7 Saturn 5 never failed the
biggest most complex machine ever built
never failed not one time Apollo 7 went
at Earth orbit with good old Wally
schirra being the commander tested it
out and it wasn't more than a few months
later they the United States was afraid
that the Russians were going to win the
race cheaply by taking one cosmonaut
putting him in one small capsule and
launching him around the moon and they
could say well we went to the moon first
no matter what happened after that so in
December of 1968 the second time that
humans flew on the Saturn 5 and an
Apollo capsule we went to the moon lunar
orbit went right around the moon stayed
up there orbited a few times and then
came back Apollo 9 we went back into
Earth orbit and did some demonstrations
about going outside what they call Eevee
a extra vehicle activity Apollo 10 lunar
orbit taking the limb the lander
detaching going down within a few miles
they made it deliberately heavy so but
Pete Conrad was flying that he would
have landed but they made it a little
bit too heavy for him to get off so even
he said I'm not gonna do it so so then
came of course Apollo 11 which we know
as as Neil Armstrong Buzz Aldrin's
flight where they landed on the moon
raised a flag and this is one small step
for man one giant leap for mankind and
we had done it 1969 July of 1969
just as Kennedy had promised that we
would do it about 11 12 14 15 16 and 17
we landed on the moon we brought back a
half a ton of rocks we did if somebody
make jewelry out of that can you imagine
how much money you'd be wearing honey
I'm sorry I messed up but here's a rock
made from the moon yeah
Just My Little Dream but anyway it was
amazing and Apollo 13 we all know about
it it was a spectacular but inspiring
failure and then it was all over it was
all over we pulled the plug on the whole
thing there was a couple reasons for
that one thing was that we had done what
we said we were going to do we had
created all these new technologies that
were spun off and they were going great
guns I mean everything technology wise
that we have today from from cell phones
and our computers and everything else
ultimately you peel the onion back
you'll find the Apollo program it's just
pretty amazing that it had had done all
that there was a lot of concerns within
NASA about continuing the program after
Apollo 13 we were kind of afraid that
we're going to ultimately lose the crew
and we didn't want to do that after we
had had such great success so they were
all ready to say okay we did it and
let's build the shuttle and and so
that's what happened the Saturn 5
program was stopped completely Verner
von Braun was kicked upstairs to
headquarters where he was sidelined and
basically not given much to do till he
retired a few years later he died of
colon cancer all the German all his
German rocket team were basically
ordered to retire they didn't need them
anymore and so it was really just done
and then during all of that time there
was Vietnam in Vietnam was going on all
at that time and so there was this great
great struggle between what was going on
there our society was changing we had
done what we set out to do so
it was done so but ultimately the space
program of the 1960's gave us the space
program of today and I'm not sure that's
a good thing
NASA right now is busily rebuilding the
Saturn 5 they call it the SLS great big
chemical rocket and they're building the
Orion which is basically a larger
version of the Apollo capsule and as far
as NASA is concerned of a shuttle era
was interesting but kind of a divergence
and now we're going to go back to the
future if we will but but is that what
we're going to do I got my doubts for
one thing there's this fellow by the
name of Elon Musk
who's running an outfit called SpaceX
who this very week is going to launch
great big rocket called Falcon Heavy has
about half a thrust of the saturn v for
no apparent reason he's launching a red
Tesla and this solar orbit he is it's
pretty amazing and also Jeff Bezos has
his Blue Origin company and they're
going to build some big bad rockets and
so that may change everything we really
don't know what's going to come out of
this III think it's a very positive
development I really do
Elon has his eye on Mars ultimately but
of course I'm a moon guy that's it I
mean hey I think we should go to the
moon in mind a blame thing I really do
it's covered with helium-3 which is the
perfect fuel for fusion reactors severe
shortage of fusion reactors but hey
we'll get there so so I think these
rockets that Elon is building and basis
a building it will take us back to the
moon they'll say we're going to go there
to Matt to see what it's like living on
Mars we're going to develop all the
technology we need but I think once we
get to the moon we're going to fight and
find it so interesting we're going to
spend a couple of generations there I
hope that some of you students will go
up there and and live raise your
families on the moon I think that
right I'm serious come on it's 1/6
gravity got a little gravity things will
happen so all I know is this I lived
through the 1960s it was an incredible
exciting time but I hope we never have
another decade like it please not
everything at once please let's go into
space let's do the other things but
let's do them in a rational way a way
that will build on and leave an
infrastructure and like Apollo which was
all thrown away that may if such as
possible yet lead the human family to
the Stars and what an adventure that
will be thank you very much
okay
I didn't do too bad on time so we're
good thank you mr. Hickman has
graciously agreed to sign copies of his
book October sky immediately following
the lecture right outside in the
Phillips Lobby we now have time for a
few questions please wait raise your
hand and wait for the microphone to be
brought to you
did I mention if it you can look it up
on Wikipedia don't just get thank you so
much for speaking mr. Hickam yes so you
talked a little bit about developments
in private space and I'm wondering what
do you think NASA's priorities should be
as we go into the 21st century yeah well
I think what the folks down at Marshall
Space Flight Center should be doing
which is still rocket City should be
doing is building advanced propulsion
systems I mean we know how to build a
chemical rocket so I don't know that we
need to rebuild the Saturn 5 let's let
the commercial people do that I'd like
to see new ion engines I'd like to see
nuclear engines fusion engines some way
that we can get beyond chemical rockets
in the chemical rockets you know it's a
sham that we're saying we're going to
Mars you can't go to Mars on chemical
rockets takes 10 months when Mars is
closest to get out there with chemical
rockets
you're basically drifting through space
and at SUV for 10 months they proposed
sending well we'll send a husband and
wife and I said good luck on that
if you choose me I'm gonna take my cat
and a good book that's what I want yeah
I'm sorry I love my wife but I don't
think we've know and and and we'd uh we
don't know after ten months in in
weightlessness whether they're going to
be able to have enough physical strength
to descend onto Mars and walk around we
don't know what will happen in terms of
radiation during that entire ten months
we need a big bed rocket that will get
us out there in a big hurry and that's
the nuclear rocket well just get us on
out there in a week or two no more than
a month that's the way to go to Mars so
anytime they're saying we're going to
Mars we're building this SLS to go to
Mars they're pulling your leg that's not
going to happen thank you for joining us
today I don't mean to digress but would
you oh sorry
would you make a couple of comments
about the Rosenbergs passing our nuclear
rocket technology versus Bill Clinton
passing our nuclear rocket technology to
the North Koreans I'm glad I didn't get
a political question ease
I vaguely remember the road I was
actually alive during that time I can
feel sorry for him they killed him they
they they they electrocuted him didn't
put them in the they put them in an
electric chair they thought they were
doing a good thing my reading on it the
Rosenberg saw it oh well the Soviet
Union are falling behind we better help
them catch up we need parity in the
world we're gonna or the you know we're
gonna have a nuclear war so that was
kind of my take on the Rosenbergs I feel
sorry for anybody that gets trapped in
electric chair I'm sorry but and that
includes Bill Clinton that hadn't
happened yet I don't know I don't know
but I think the North Koreans they did
get some of our technology certainly I
think the Clinton Bill Clinton basically
slid over a lot of our guidance
technology to the Chinese that's what
that's where that happened for whatever
reason I don't know but and that
ultimately almost everything the Chinese
knows about rocket technology ultimately
the North Koreans know about it I don't
have any sense that the North Koreans
really have the capability yet hit
anything other than the Pacific Ocean so
I think we're okay but we but we
obviously it's obviously something that
we need to diplomatically work on kind
of following up on what you just said
about that North Korea is always looming
over us and and we kind of heard some
discussion about resurrecting some SDI
technology and kind of that approach to
national defense as a former NASA
engineer what are your thoughts on how
NASA and space might play a role in our
national defense and foreign policy yeah
I mean actually NASA is kept by charter
from working on military projects they
don't do it this does not mean that
there's a lot of cross currents going on
obviously an engineer works for NASA can
work for the Air Force of the army or
the contractors who do so a lot of that
technology has definitely been
transferred it was originally
transferred from the military to the
civilian side
with with NASA SDI is as feasible and we
actually do have a number of defensive
anti-missile missile systems on United
States Navy war craft that are stationed
off of Korea and in the Pacific that
that if we see them launch and we really
think that it's coming our way that we
might be able to catch them we shall say
that a lot of human intelligence is
required there that we know of it that
they're about to do it we have
satellites we're watching them very very
closely
it is a obviously a real real problem
and it's one that technologically we can
probably defend ourselves but there's
always just one little one little
nuclear warhead to get through I mean
it's the problem with the Cold War as
much as we we even when there was just
bombers we always felt like at least one
bomber would get through and you know it
doesn't take much for nuclear weapons
the first place just knock out all
electronics knock out the internet and
and all of our computers and we're we're
just in big trouble so it doesn't take
very much to knock an advanced society
like us down and this is what scares us
about North Korea they only have to get
that nuclear warhead over one so
obviously I think we do need to beef up
our Strategic Defense Initiative but I
mean often Lee we defeated the Soviet
Union and I think we can defeat North
Korea but it's going to take it's going
to take a lot of diplomacy and we almost
just have to wait them out until the
people just can't take it anymore and
rise up and get rid of that awful awful
government like in Iran
it'll happen the Iranian people are way
too sharp to stick with the mullahs
forever they'll get rid of them
eventually thank you for speaking mr.
Hickam
I was curious what was your favorite
part about working for NASA
oh gosh um I you know I love being a
writer that's what I that's what I've
done for the last 20 years and that I
just love to write but by golly I loved
working for NASA I woke up every morning
said oh boy I get to go work for NASA
today it was cool it really was and my
job was to train the astronauts I took
it because I felt like it'd be an easy
job the astronauts already knew
everything or thought they did and so I
get to travel all over the world with
NASA I probably my favorite - I got two
favorites with NASA I get to work on
Space Lab J which was the first
japanese-american human spaceflight and
go over and live in Japan for a whole
year and train the Japanese astronauts
and my gosh that was a lot of fun and
then I got to work on the Hubble Space
Telescope after after it was found to be
nearsighted I had nothing to do with
that up today so I got to work
underwater actually in the spacesuit
underwater at the neutral buoyancy
simulator in Huntsville Alabama training
story Musgrave and his crew to go up and
repair the Hubble and that was what a
great adventure that was that's two of
my favorites we have time for one more
question I thank you so much for coming
to speak here um given your experience
with training astronauts do you think in
the future with Tesla and the commercial
and SpaceX and the commercialization of
space exploration in the industry is
there still a sort of requirement for
astronauts to have sort of military
experience they've had great question
and and and embedded in that question do
we still need the federal astronaut
corps most all Americans go down to
Houston and trained in the astronaut
office down there it's at the only
resource that we can get for astronauts
I think the answer is now I believe that
ultimately the the commercial folks are
going to
their own set astronauts for different
reasons and so we're really going to
expand the pool of astronauts over the
next 10 or 20 years beyond that very
very selective and very very good group
of folks down in Houston and that's
going to be exciting to see to see all
of that open up and I'm serious about
families going and living on the moon
there's stuff to do on the moon we used
to talk about going out and getting an
asteroid you know going way out and
bringing an asteroid and and looking at
that I said look under every crater on
the moon what are you gonna find an
asteroid let's go there and look and so
if you want to look at an asteroid by
the way we think there's a lot of gold
on the moon so maybe we're looking at
the 49ers yeah see there's gold in them
thar hills let's go to the moon let's
live there get to my mind speaking
politically if you have some poor child
crawl out of the hut somewhere wherever
it is and they live in a society where
they're suppressed and depressed and
they look up at the moon and they
realize there are people up there living
on the moon don't you think that they
will aspire to be like those people I
think so
the moon is the greatest advertisement
for Western civilization there yes
if we're up there living on the moon so
let's go make that happen thank you very
much
[Applause]